as Thais enjoy the easing of Kovac 19
restrictions many remain reliant on food
handouts from charities and local
communities and in some cases there's
not enough to go around for those who've
been waiting many closed businesses are
able to reopen after almost two months
of being shut but the state of emergency
remains in place along with the 10:00
p.m. to 4:00 a.m. curfew the ban on
international flights to Thailand
continues until the end of the month
restaurants can have dine in customers
but only one person per table and no
alcohol for ciri Wong a pet soon on it's
better than nothing but it might be too
late I'm very worried about the tourism
industry Thais don't have the same
purchasing power as foreign visitors the
Chinese Koreans and Japanese spend a lot
of money but they're all gone I think it
may even take a year for things to get
better
the government will evaluate the
situation every two weeks
either determining to further ease the
restrictions or if there's a spike in
confirmed cases reimpose some of the
rules while the government is very much
focused on the here and now of tackling
kovat 19 there's growing concern about
the future some businesses opening up is
good news but this country is so reliant
on the tourism industry that's at a
standstill
like the empty streets here in old
Bangkok there are many types of
businesses connected with tourism so a
downturn cuts deep into the population
here we are an economy that depends a
lot on globalization we depend a lot on
the movement of people in terms of our
dependence on tourism
I think contributing to nearly 20
percent of the GDP we also depend
heavily on export pet grooming shops
have also opened their doors the owner
of bark lounge used her personal savings
to keep the business afloat
for her it paid off a lot of my
customers are starting to come back I
think because my shop was closed for a
long time during the temporary shutdown
my clients had no choice since the
government lifted some of the
restrictions my customers are fighting
to be the first in line Thailand's
southern neighbor Malaysia also began
loosening kovat restrictions
most businesses including restaurants
can reopen but some states are keeping
restrictions in place they want more
time to study the potential risks from
relaxing the kerbs
back in the cramped low-income
neighborhoods of Bangkok many don't work
in the industries or businesses that
have reopened so they still need the
food handouts but there's hope that this
is a first step that could lead to more
restrictions being lifted and that they
soon can return to providing for their
families on their own scott Heidler al
Jazeera Bangkok